activité pendant la guerre autre
réaction très vive cet après midi celle
de maurice papon qui venait d'être
officiellement inculpé à bordeaux pour
crimes contre l'humanité toujours
pendant cette dernière guerre nous avons
exposé le dossier hier soir c'est une
manipulation politique de la douleur
quarante ans après at il dit avant de
réfuter catégoriquement les accusations
de ses détracteurs connaissez-vous avoir
signé les ordres d'arrestation et
d'acheminement vers drancy
absolument pas et ce n'était d'ailleurs
pas dans mes fonctions parce que comme
je les ai dit je n'avais aucun espèce de
pouvoirs de police et à l'est un préfet
régional avait un attendant régional de
police y avait un directeur
départemental de la police moi j'étais
secrétaire général administratif de la
gironde
est ce que je faisais et je m'honore
c'était effectivement lorsqu'il y avait
c'est malheureux qu'on voit de mérignac
à drancy
c'était de fournir des couvertures des
boissons chaudes de n'occuper que des
enfants de mobiliser la croix rousse de
mobiliser eagle toutes les bonnes
volontés de l'époque pour alléger la
souffrance de ces malheureuses personnes
vous ne reconnaissez pas avoir signé des
documents et des recommandations à la
gendarmerie turque ou d'options halal
gendarmes pays pour acheminer les gens
mérignac il j'avais effectivement des
escortes
si vous voulez que des convois et lieu
pour des raisons que je comprends et que
je partage
le grand rabbin cohen suppliait que
c'est que convoi fut juste accompagné
par des gendarmes français
parce que chaque convoi qui était
accompagné par l'affect gendarmes wayuu
par la gestapo les pauvres personnes qui
étaient dans un combat étaient traités
comme du bétail ce qui n'arrivait tout
de même pas mettre les gens dans le
français en quelque sorte monsieur papon
vous étiez un agent double je te pas du
tout agent double parce que pour la taz
en double il aurait fallu que je fusse a
adjoint des allemands ce que je n'étais
pas monsieur
un dernier mot monsieur papou
face à l'histoire face à vous même le
matin ou le soir dans votre miroir vous
êtes contents de vous on n'est jamais
content de soi parce qu'on n'a jamais
fini de faire son devoir
sur cette terre telle qu'elle est et
avec les hommes tels qu'ils sont mais si
j'avais à refaire ce que j'ai fait je le
referais par ailleurs jean le gall
ancien délégué en zone occupée du
secrétaire général la police du
gouvernement de vichy a été interrogé
hier pendant près de trois heures par un
juge d'instruction à paris martine
anzani lui aussi avait été inculpé de
crimes contre l'humanité il y a quatre
ans georges marchais réclame